conquering fear in general right right
if you're a failure or fear of rejection
for the unknown what would your advice
be to someone who wants us like start a
business or a major project but they're
but they're held back by fear so this is
again it's interesting for me because
public speaking is not something that
induces fear made it never has but I
know that it does make people scared and
I think that overcoming the key to any
overcoming any fear in my mind is we
talked about earlier which is
inoculation and this idea and I actually
looked up the definition of inoculation
and it's the introduced the introduction
of a pathogen or antigen into a living
organism to stimulate the production of
antibiotic antibodies so you're giving
yourself a little bit right you give
yourself a little bit and you build up
off there and and that's what you do you
take the small doses so it prepares you
for the big bigger doses and I one of my
daughters my middle daughter she was
really wanting to be in the school play
right and other plays around town and
you know okay cool well that's cool but
she was horrified to go out in front of
an audience
horrified and so I looked up and I said
okay how do you stop in your kids from
being getting stage fright is one they
call it and you know I read about people
what they did and what I did was I said
I'd say okay
sing a song for me and it's not that big
of a deal cuz I'm her dad and so she'd
sing a song for me and even then she'd
be a little bit embarrassed but she'd
sing a song for it and then you know a
couple days they'd write my wife hey
sing that song for both of us mm-hmm and
then it was oh my wife's got a friend
over hey sing that song for the three of
us cuz I are you get a mystery person an
unknown in the room okay so she's
overcoming that fear and each time she's
getting a little bit more and more
confident because we took her to what
are they called tryouts what's tryout
called
audition audition we took her to a
couple auditions where
it was her turn and she didn't go she
broke down just crying and just just
just couldn't handle it mm-hmm and so
then it was then it was a few my wife's
friends were over then it was some of my
friends were over so now you got you
know guys and girls and each time she
got more and more confident and
eventually she just didn't care anymore
and she was totally confident and she
got the lead role in the school play she
legitimately got the lead role in the
school play so so she was able to
overcome that fear and in the SEAL Teams
we do the same kind of thing we know
where you're gonna get inoculated
against stress as much as they can
stress you out in the SEAL Teams they're
gonna stress you out there's going to be
machine-gun fire you're gonna be used to
that there's gonna be explosions going
off you're gonna be used to that we used
to do we used to fly fire machine-gun
drills and and and I add drills
immediate action drills we are
maneuvering around we should do that
without your ear protection and
sometimes so you get used to this crazy
banging we don't do that anymore because
it's not smart but uh but you do that to
inoculate it's like what you were
talking about earlier when that gun goes
off you should be completely comfortable
with it and there's an one of my
favorite stories on that one my
favorites or spo11 a buddy of mine who
actually took my job I was at a ski -
commander he actually took my job as
tasking a commander and a flashbang is a
grenade that you throw into a room
before you go into the room and it makes
a loud explosion and smoke and then it
allows you to enter in on the room when
the people that are inside are now
startled so you have an advantage well
occasionally you know you have to open
the door to throw the crash in there and
occasionally someone will open the door
and someone will run in by eglee didn't
coordinate it well and so the open the
door
guy runs in and then someone throws the
crash and so now you're crashing
yourself it's not that big of a deal you
gotta used to it but what happened with
one of his new guys you know that
happened so the door would open the guy
went in and while the guy's running in
somebody throws a crash in there the guy
sees the crash and he runs back out of
the room which is not what you're
supposed to do so this guy was the
tasking commander he goes hey come with
me down here and so they walked down and
he brought him into a closet in the kill
house and just sat in there and said
yeah
how's it going and then just sat there
in the dark and dropped like eight
crashes at their feet and just boss the
guy because you realize you just got to
get inoculated you just got to overcome
it so that's kind of I guess my my
theory here would be if you're afraid of
fighting and altercations go change it
so if you're afraid of heights work on
some rock climbing climbing if you're
afraid of the water time to swim it's
time to surf it's trying to get out
there if you're afraid of pull-ups if if
you're prey to pulps do pull-ups if
you're in squats do squats if you're
afraid of public speaking go speak in
public mm-hmm if you're afraid to start
a business start a business make it
small and on all these what you have to
do is you have to mitigate the risk and
you have to ease yourself into it but
you got to go for it and eventually you
will overcome that fear but the hard
part is you got to take that first step
you got to take that first step to begin
to inoculate yourself against the fear
against the fear of the thing that's in
your mind because that fear generally is
in your mind yeah you know when you get
up on stage do a public speaking people
are not going to throw tomatoes at you
and say oh my you're an idiot get off
the stage now they're gonna sit there
you know so there's nothing to fear yeah
it's in it's in your head